In this video we'll show you how to schedule scans in Burpsuite Enterprise Edition.
Before we get started, just be aware that you can only create scans for sites that you've
already added to the system, so if you haven't created any sites yet please check out our
previous video for details on how to do this.
So once you've got your site set up, you've got a few different options for creating a
scan.
You can either drill down into the site and just click the new scan button, in which case
the site is pre-selected for you.
Alternatively, from anywhere in Burpsuite Enterprise Edition you can hover over the scans menu and
select create a new scan.
In this case you'll just need to select the site from the drop down menu.
So the first thing you need to decide is when you want your scan to start.
You can either schedule it to begin as soon as possible, or schedule it for a specific
time in the future.
For example, if you're scanning a site that other people are using to perform acceptance
testing you might want to schedule it to run overnight to avoid any impact on performance.
I'm going to schedule my scan to run at midnight.
Next, you can choose whether to create a one-off scan or create a recurring scan that repeats
on a regular basis.
I'll set my scan to run once per day.
By default, all recurring scans run indefinitely, but you can also specify a fixed number of repetitions,
or schedule the scan to run until a specific date.
Scan configurations give you really granular control over how Burps scan will behave, and
what sorts of issues it will check for.
There are plenty of built-in configurations for limiting the crawl time, restricting which
audit checks are performed, and generally just fine-tuning the scan to achieve better coverage
or speed, depending on what your priority is.
This can be really useful if you just want to get quick feedback, especially if you're
planning to incorporate the scan as part of a CI-CD workflow, for example.
If you're a Burpsuite professional user, you'll notice that most of the same built-in scan configurations
are available here.
You can also choose to create your own custom scan configurations, but we'll cover that in
a separate video.
It's worth pointing out at this stage that you don't actually have to select any scan configurations.
If you just leave this section blank, then Burpscanner will just use its default configuration, which
provides a good balance between coverage and speed.
You only need to add a configuration here if you want to override a particular setting or
group of settings.
If you click on the question mark next to each configuration, you can see exactly which setting
it overrides.
All of the options are grouped according to the kind of behaviour they control, so if a
section's collapsed, like the login functions one here, this means that all of the settings
in that area are unchanged from Burpscanner's standard configuration.
So as you can see here, applying this particular configuration hardly affects any of the settings,
but you will notice that the Crawl Limits section is expanded.
This shows us that one or more settings in this group are different from the standard configuration.
As you can probably tell from the name, applying this particular configuration just changes the
maximum crawl time to 30 minutes.
So going back to our scan, you probably noticed that a couple of scan configurations were already
pre-selected.
These are the default configurations that I specified when I created this site.
Whenever you're creating a new scan, you're free to override these defaults if you want to.
So this time I might want to run a slightly more thorough scan than usual, so I'll make a
couple of changes.
I'll set the audit coverage thorough configuration and crawl strategy most complete.
As you can see, you can select multiple different configurations for the same scan, and these
are all applied in sequence, so you can combine several smaller configurations to create an overall
configuration that's tailored specifically for this particular site or for what you're trying
to achieve with this scan.
So now I'm happy with everything, I can go ahead and save.
As you can see, the scan's now scheduled.
Until it actually starts running, you've got the option to edit which scan configurations
are going to be applied, and you can also change the scheduling information if you want to.
If you choose to start your scan immediately, the scan status will indicate that it's waiting
for the next available agent.
Ideally, this should only take a few moments while the scan's initialised, but it does
depend on your licence and how many scans you already have running.
So if you've got a licence for 10 agents, for example, this means you can run up to 10 scans
at the same time.
Obviously, if you've already got 10 scans running, you'll have to wait until one of the
others has finished before this one can start.
This limitation also affects any scans that you've scheduled for a particular time of
day, so try to keep this in mind when you schedule new scans so that they don't all
coincide.
Remember that as your needs grow, you can add more agents to your licence at any time by
going to your account page on portswiger.net.
And that's how you schedule a new scan in Berksuite Enterprise Edition.
Thank you.